[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happy playing tuesday you tapped into
the group chat live in the bleacher
report app presented by fanduel my name
is cabbie richards
she always brings the best betting
expertise that is aaron dolan
from fanduel and many times on the show
we open up the
bel air academy playbook and we just
passed the rock to g-money that is greg
ivory
welcome lady and welcome jet fanduel is
uh hooking us hooking it up for the
playing games
this week with their play in palooza all
customers will receive a risk-free bet
for the plans between tuesday and friday
so check out fanduel for more info
look guys back on christmas day nobody
would have predicted that two legacy
franchises the boston celtics
the los angeles lakers and the team of
the 2010s
the golden state warriors would be in
the playing tournament
right now but here we are you know and
each week on our in our chuck versus
america segment
uh we go toe-to-toe with the two-time
hall of fame we got a couple of
mvps in this conversation but we go
head-to-head with a two-time hall of
famer
and also congratulations for earning the
kurt gowdy
uh transformative media award during
hall of fame
weekend chuckster so congrats once again
sir uh while that is a w
in our last matchup in chuck vs america
we both took l so let's take a look at
the latest standings
in our chuck versus america segment
which we love every week
we're at 11 of five and the truck stairs
creeping up at nine
and seven but all that matters to money
is that we're still ahead
and you're still generous with your
handy dandy ipad
aaron and people that are at home this
right here that thing daddy ipad and
this is how you get hoodies yes this is
a lot of vibes on this ipad
uh here we go i'm in the comments i am
in the comments 22 goldie 22 goldie he's
spamming us in the comments
he has over 50 comments of the same
comments and he never won his hoodie
brother we will give you your hoodie you
can stop spamming the comments uh
let me actually you're walking away with
a hoodie twenty-two golden
eagles how about that wait you wait day
mom he gave that day mom eight
person hoodie yeah give him another
hoodie so he can stop spamming the
comments like
it's love here brother it is love here
all love
a lot of good vibes 22 goatees and
you're walking away with a hoodie
we're gonna we are gonna dm you uh j mom
eight
j mom ape says tatum will clap the
wizard shout out to you you walk away
woody
nick freita nick frato gave us the
bradley bill gift
you guys see it right here there it is
yes nick you are walking away with a
hoodie and uh
that's it that's it for now cabbie
that's it okay that's it you are you are
definitely calling bro you start off the
show with like 19 hoodies man
so tonight we're going head-to-head with
the great charles barkley in our
favorite
chuck versus america and earlier today
we asked you on hood
on on twitter excuse me who will score
more points today in washington versus
boston
jayson tatum minus 142 or bradley beal
plus 112 and america is voting
bradley beal at pl at 70 oh
whoo greg uh who's that when you see
more in the comments
beal or tatum let me ask let me actually
ask him cabbie
uh you guys get in the comments let me
know i need gifts need a lot of gifts
take over the comments with gifts uh
need bradley bill jason tatum
let me know who you guys thinks uh who
you guys think is going to score more
points today aaron
bradley bill came in second uh for the
scoring title this year for a reason i
mean
he's he he can ball he's plus money
how tempting is it to take him in this
spot very tempting i mean he averaged 41
points in the last three meetings
against boston
shooting 46 from three-point line
against boston then in td garden 47
from that three-point line so i know a
lot of people saying they're taking a
gamble on beale here given that he's not
fully healthy as he said with that
lingering hamstring issue but
i'm going bradley build especially a
plus money
what aaron but how his hamstring we saw
like
james harden miss he'll be fine a month
we'll be fine he'll be fine
wait do you know something that we don't
know this is a play in tournament game
you have to play well yeah it's playoff
time all the injuries just
hold off till the end of the game i
don't know i know it do you guys see
this dude
he was wincing on the sidelines in the
last game
cabbie those are bad vibes bro like guys
relax
this is this is the playing game the
playing case winning game
real estate i got a
uh drizzy here from his song thank you
later the idols become your rivals
mike make friends with mike but got an
ai for your survival so
jason tatum bradley beal five years
apart
they're both from st louis they both
went to the same high school
they both had their jerseys retired at
that same high school
they're friends and they work out in the
off season
idols become your rivals jayson tatum is
that dude he's six
foot ten and can score it all three
levels at the rim
in the at the mid-range which he loves
and then beyond the arc
who is gonna guard jayson tatum tonight
guys on washington
rui hatchimal sure it's bradley beal
loves out of simon
but on that hamstring i mean six ten
six three bradley beal give me jason
all day idols become the rivals i'll
take that fully healthy
jayson tatum over a beal with a left
hamstring injury
uh g-money who do you love in this
matchup and who does the audience love
cabbie i'm gonna get there uh let me get
into the let me get into these comments
because i see a lot and i mean a lot of
bradley bill
uh gifts i got motive aided
motivated shout out to you your walk
away what are you look at the bradley
bill gif
rally fired up yeah right there flex on
them
yeah there it is there it is bradley i
need i got
fired up bradley m go blue
16 m go blue 16 got got another bradley
bill gif
uh he's he's actually smiling in this
one he's smiling this one there's the
gif right there guys
uh shout out to everybody i said that's
walking away with a hoodie
one more jmoney bwa jd money bwa says
bradley bill is gonna have
more than 40 points tonight shout out to
you uh
i would love to side bet that prime 40
points i got to jump in the comments
aside that
there's no way bradley beal scoring 40
tonight go ahead g money
aaron's sitting there with the plus
money uh
the comments are they're they're they're
they're they're
they're yelling i mean not yelling but
they're saying bill they're
they're they're yelling through gifts
they're there's there's literally a
bunch of bradley bill gifts
in the comments uh so with that being
said man i'm gonna have to rock with
bradley i feel like
he's gonna have to show up you're you're
asking who's gonna guard jayson tatum
yeah
i mean cabbie who's going to guard
bradley bill marcus
i know you said he had the marcus smart
is uh oh
bro he's one of the best come on he's a
dog but he's not
cabbie do you really believe marcus
smart can guard bradley
you really believe that oh cabby
i don't even know i don't even think
marcus smart believes he can't like
bradley bill 101 isolation mono imano
marcus smart bradley bill you think he
can guard him really bradley beal is one
of the most
underrated and under-appreciated
basketball
players in the association brad marco
smart is legit listen
jaylen brown not being in the game
definitely hurts like if jaylen brown
was playing
the marcus could focus all his attention
on bradley beal
but still but he's gonna step up he's
been he's played in eastern conference
finals
series like this guy is built for this
give me marcus smart
bradley beale listen he markers smart he
might get to 30 points but he might have
to take
30 shots or 35 shots tonight to get
there
marcus smart is a dog he's a dog but i
don't know about the one-on-one with
bradley bill
i'm taking bradley i'm taking bradley
okay well listen
america check out the iconic inside the
nba
pre-game show on tnt to find out who
the great charles barkley is riding with
and i have a feeling he's going to side
with america and bradley beal
make sure you get on fanduel and bet the
head-to-head matchup as well
today is three by tuesday and the
question is will there be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes of the game last week
we locked in a 3x2 in miami versus
boston
and just like that it hit as always
let's take a look
remember we were just talking about
marcus smart right there in the corner
that's my guy buddy he had a couple of
three-pointers in that game and then
evan fournier who came over in the trade
at the deadline
ball movement leading it to him ever 48.
he had four in that game you know
like both teams combined for 50 from
downtown it was
absolute fireworks crazy we cashed
another three by two
that's how we do yeah uh g money
which matchup do you do you and the
winners only army army excuse me
uh want to lock in tonight for the three
by two they they want to lock in
the pacers and the hornets or the
wizards and the celtics
cabbie uh let me ask let me ask the
people uh
which three by two do you guys think we
should rock
uh rock witch should it be charlotte
indiana or should it be washington
boston you guys let me know get in the
comments
aaron indiana and washington are both
teams that score a lot of points you
know that they're sick they're top six
in scoring
shooters all around which game are you
leaning towards
charlotte indiana washington against
boston i'm going washington boston this
one i mean the hornet's pacers game
seems to be a mess right now with
players out like
carousel vert with the health and safety
protocols and you have de monte sabonis
questionable in that matchup as well so
i think the best chance for your
two here wizards versus the celtics no
doubt
i'm right there i disagreed with you
last time aaron but i'm with you on this
one
the the celtics have limped into the
play in tournament losing six of their
last game so there's
six for the last game eight games excuse
me so there's some urgency
over there with boston and if you
subscribe to the next man up theory
because
jason uh sorry jalen brown is out with
season ending
wrist surgery then you gotta look at
evan fournier and kemba walker as the
two
as two guys to get it started with the
celtics
those are the dudes i'm looking at for
the three by two so let's lock in
wizards and celtics uh tonight uh where
does your
winners only army want to sprinkle uh
g-money
how much gabby i am i'm in the comments
right now i am in the commons giving
away hoodies
uh i see a lot
i see actually i see a whole bunch of
stuff i got
i got been the mvp been the mvp is
rocking with uh he's rocking with boston
boston washington shout out to you ben
the mvp you're walking with a hoodie
taylor payne taylor payne has watched
walk rocking with the boston uh
washington game
to campaign walk away with hoodie uh
i don't know maybe
jesse jesse bolanos jesse bolanos
washington versus boston they have more
fire power
shout out to you you're a walk away with
a hoodie uh
there's a lot of love for washington and
boston there's a lot of love for
washington
which game are you locking in honey
there's also another game
being played today charlotte versus
indiana
i mean the odds are plus 100 for a
reason i feel like i mean
let's show some love to this game too
here's the here's what i think cabbie
and aaron i think both three by twos are
going to hit i'm going to put those
vibes into the atmosphere but i just
want to show some love
to charlotte and indiana here they have
shooters all around the shooters are on
the court
terry scary terry lamello on one team
indiana i mean i know davonte graham
definitely i i know that they got the
news with the what
you know uh carousel burt not playing
but they they they score points we
we talked about it already earlier in
the show show some love to charlotte
indiana
and then take that money and put it on
washington boston and have yourself a
day yeah we needed to love them
so i'm glad you picked that we needed
some love on that person
we did all right all right well good
luck g money i know you
are are you doing a an uh an instagram
live tonight
ig live yeah we will be live tonight uh
riding a three by two okay uh we just
have to pick which one we have to figure
out which one we're riding with and
that's the one we're gonna take
to instagram later on okay we'll tap
into the br betting
ig uh account for for the live
experience with greg ivory bring your
sunset vibes bring your positive vibes
good vibes only and then make sure uh to
tap in with br betting social to get the
link
to the 3x2 for either pacers and hornets
or wizards and celtics there's no
official word on whether lebron james is
a fan
of the show the queen's gambit or the
movie fresh
is one of his favorite movies with the
legendary sam jackson
but we know that lebron james has been
playing 4d chess
for a long time so every time he
publicly praises
his rival steph curry by calling him the
mvp this year
or at the all-star weekend throwing up
various hashtags on twitter
like hashtag change uh greatest shooter
of all time or
hashtag let me get this changed how the
game is played by himself
alone we're skeptical
aaron do you think that this is do you
think that he's being genuine
do you think he's this is some
gamesmanship from lebron
or is he recruiting without recruit
i mean you can never deny that he can
recruit players because he has lebron
james but i also think
i'm not sure if it's genuine i just
think lebron loves to stir up the drama
and get people talking i mean we're
talking about on the show that's exactly
what lebron james wants i'm not sure if
he's tuning into this right now
but i feel like he loves that he drives
off it so i'm not really sure but
yeah we can assume lebron james is
watching this show
absolutely he's a huge fan of br and
definitely fan of uh br betting he just
won't reveal to us which
games he's sprinkling on but that's okay
the audience will let us know uh
where to put the money on tonight where
to get in the action so g-money
who's a lock to hit their player totals
for tomorrow's game
golden state inside the staples center
are
are they riding with wardell steph curry
or lebron
raymond james
cabbie let me ask him let me get into
the comments and ask you guys uh
hey who's hitting they're over who's in
there over tomorrow we're going with
steph curry
yes or lebron james uh you guys let me
know get in the comments let me know
aaron who do you think is hitting their
point total tomorrow
i mean both of these are so high stefan
and played each other 22 times
and all been in the nba finals which is
a pretty crazy stat to think about
but i feel like if i have to pick
between these two i have to go steph
curry i mean i know it is so
high we know he just won that spraying
title he's also the first player 33
years or older to lead the league in
scoring since
michael jordan i mean he's shooting
lights out he's averaging 32 points as
single elimination steph put in this
spot
i think if i'm going to pick somebody to
go over i'd pick him
well that's it i i agree with you aaron
that steph curry is at the height of his
powers and
just won his second nba scoring title
but lakers head coach frank vogel is a
tactician
and the lakers have a great defense even
though anthony davis and lebron james
missed a ton of time so they're going to
be
double teaming him throwing in some
traps and they're gonna try to contain
steph curry
36 and a half points is a very high
total
so i'm staying away from that even
though steph curry has the hot hand so
if anything
i would come under the total i'm gonna
i'm gonna side with the play-making
facilitator
lebron james this is a big moment his
legacy is at stake
braun's gonna show up he always does so
give me the over 26.5 points
and i don't think steph curry's gonna
have the clamps on but i don't think
he's gonna get to
uh 37 points g-money are you riding with
la
or the bay the bay
clear i mean 37 points in staples that's
a lot bro
let me i thought we had to pick which
one we thought would hit over though
if we're gonna i feel like you know
yeah aaron you're absolutely right
you're right
like we we do think steph curry's gonna
hit the over i mean i do think that but
let me let me get into these comments
and then i'll take on to my take
uh i got eddie on the go he's rocking
with you cabbie and lebron james
lebron's
celebrating this championship right
there nice uh shout out to you eddie on
the go you're walking away with a hoodie
j-rock 8480 rocking with shimmy steph
uh joe yan is in the comments they're
both rocking with shimmy steph right
there
shout out to you guys you guys are
walking away with hoodies uh
cabbie i see a lot of stuff i see a lot
of braun will show up eddie on the go
shout out to you again
saying brown will show up but uh and she
and a lot of stuff in the comments which
former mvp are you going with
g-money can you can you at i i mean for
once in your life be
uh objective in uh in a selection
or is it always yeah i mean i'm i'm
always i'm i'm
always objective no you're what like i'm
always the
opposite of objective i use a lot of i
use a lot of i use a lot of logic
i use a lot of logic and in this case in
this case steph curry
is the alpha on this where's two he's
the alpha everyone knows
i'd say dirt draymond is the alpha
all right okay as far as in scoring and
as far as in leading this team
on offense steph curry is the alpha on
this team
so with that being said the warriors
need steph curry to perform tomorrow
they absolutely need him to perform
whether they win or not
we don't know but will steph cory
performs yes
i do think steph curry will perform
lebron he just rolled his ankle at cab
he just rolled his ankle in the fourth
quarter of his last game
you think i'm gonna bet that he's gonna
go out there and give me 27 on a broad
ankle
no i'm going to take a fresh step curry
i'm going to take i'm going to
healthy steph curry it's 36 give it to
me
take it to the bank hopefully the
warriors win and we'll see
we'll see but i'm taking steph curry to
show up bronze probably got a hyperbaric
chamber at his house
or he'll like dip his foot in a block of
ice or something
he's gonna be ready braun is always
ready
uh dreamville dreamville the army not
the navy
how could you ever try to play me kill
him on a song walk about the booth
and do the uh westbrook rock of baby
j cole and i'm sorry jermaine i just
butchered your line but
he just dropped some new heat this week
and maybe
the track amari will inspire russell
westbrook tonight
and maybe it will inspire greg ivory
to actually hit a five-leg same game
parlay uh g-money let's let's hope that
um
you do better than you did two weeks ago
when you went oh for five
can we please take a look at last week's
ticket
where you went two for five okay that's
that's an improvement somewhat better
adding zero to batting 400
okay yeah yeah we're getting better
we're getting better but uh
you know i went
like in baseball in baseball when you
have a pitcher out there that's
struggling
you know usually the manager he calls
the bullpen and gets someone warmed up
and then he goes out there and make the
move last week i called on
matt dodger matt dodger mad respect to
him you know but
you know we went two and five it's that
that is okay that is our show because
i'm on my way to the mound
i'm on my way to the mail right now and
i just went like this
so i'm calling i went to the bullpen you
guys can see that went called to the
bullpen
and i tapped in with my guy polio tapped
in with my guy paulio and we came up
with this
parlay five uh same game parlay for the
washington wizards
boston celtics game we're gonna start it
off like this we're gonna start it off
like this
washington wizards plus two and a half
love that yes i think that they went out
right i think that they win this game
all right they've been
they've been bawling they have
absolutely been bawling
uh down the stretch and uh boston
you know they don't have their best
players we'll see
one of the best players one of the best
players so we'll see uh
i like the two and a half gonna take the
over here
gonna take the over here washington i
don't know how many times i said it on
the show i don't think they know what
defense is the games behind scoring
their top six they're top six in the
league and scoring themselves
so i like the over take it to the bank
we're gonna go over to my guy russ we're
gonna go over to my guy russ
go get 13 and a half give me 14 assists
russ
this is playoff basketball impossible
triple double king say it aaron triple
double king
go get me 14. go get me 14 and above man
uh this is playoff basketball it's time
to it's time it is time
brody it is time uh moving on jason
tatum
jason tatum cabbie jason took the
undertale high totals
i like the under she just shot high
total what you just said high total
like what do you totally had high totals
14 assists
westbrook yeah he's done it and when
he's wearing his he's going to except
curry numbers
these are 32 and a half these are steph
curry numbers
he isn't 30. yeah jason jason tatum
three weeks ago dropped
60 on his home court three weeks ago
against the spurs
yeah but it wasn't played yeah against
the spurs it wasn't playoff basketball
you know i mean it wasn't playoff bet
it's not they came back it was not 39
points in that game it was definitely
like playoff basketball
bro don't dis i can't believe you're
disrespecting jason tatum
my guy's 23. 6 10 and
can score this this year yeah
how many do you think tatum's gonna
score this this ain't it abby how many
of these yeah cabbie
yeah third yeah cabbie how many 37
tonight 30 plus for sure betty
30 plus for sure 34 to 37 is what
would i predict bet
it i bet it i bet the money should have
been an odds maker
all right all right
all right let's let me wrap this up can
you wrap this up
here we go uh i'm gonna go with the
first half over i think the
the full game over is gonna hit so i
think it's just gonna be a uh
uh an over over show the first half over
is gonna hit
right maybe the first quarter over is
going to hit uh full game over is going
to hit
i i i honestly do not think they know
what defense is so like give me the
points those lat ones those last two
legs this is the one
remember like beale is not 100
he had like i think it was like five for
27 in his last game
hobbling around and then and then
whoever there is lebron
made the argument that it's fine because
it's the playoffs
it's brawn though it's brah aaron come
on
hey aaron is throwing facts she's
throwing facts right at you cabbie and
i'm so happy she here
because it was kelly and cabbie against
greg
now i'm sensing some survivors this last
listen
these last two likes are problematic but
anyway let's see let's see the ticket
this week what
what what are we dealing with on a
hundred dollar bet
on a 50 bet okay we got uh okay seven to
one
or i guess it's uh 14 to one if it if we
pay out about
uh yeah 700 okay i mean that's decent
14 to 1g money what does the audience
think of this ticket yeah
shout out to my guy paulio shout out to
my guy paulie
what does the audience think of the
ticket and then are you giving any more
away any more hoodies before we get out
of here hey nick
nick frado says come on cabbie vibe with
us
man come on cabby you have to vibe with
us
uh i got raider 909 he's vibing with you
though cabbie
tatum over thirty two and a half years
he finishes with
32 to 40 points shout out to you
raider909 you are walking away with a
hoodie
uh over for the first half not
ronald acuna jr shout out to you he's
walking he's rocking with the over for
the first half you were walking over the
hoodie
uh quasar quasar
310 quasar 310 says wizards weak defense
he's scoring tatum will go off but
nothing much
else so i i think he thinks tatum's
going to go over on his point total but
don't think that they're going to win
the game
i don't know but shout out to you quasar
310 you're walk away with hoodie gabby
i'm done
okay aaron real quick do you like
g-money's ticket or do you have a prop
with any of the legs
no i really like it the only problem
that we could run into
is if for some reason this game hits
under then you lose the two legs there
because you took the first test
first half over and then of course the
end of the game as well hitting that
over but honestly the wizard's
constantly hit over so i'm not
too concerned about it but you seem
really concerned about the jayson tatum
thing is that your only leg that you're
worried about gabby
no i i'm worried about that for sure and
yeah in the first half over
first ever i'm a little bit in case
listen if these guys come out just sort
of lackadaisical or whatever and
not with the urgency that they need and
it's maybe sloppy then that one's i
think you're going to be sweating that
first i hope there would be or
definitely yes and definitely sweating
the jason tatum
do you even bet first halfs like do you
sometimes that first half so i'm betting
i'm betting on either i'm betting on the
celtics 10
and the race to 20 times you can book
that and and jason tatum a double double
but anyway that's
that's that's a for uh another stream
listen um
thank you for tapping into the group
chat presented by fanduel remember what
you learned today
some people bet emotionally and will
live with heartbreak
for the rest of their lives aka greg
ivory
next week we're back thursday so make
sure to tap in with us
mark your calendars and alongside aaron
dolan
and greg ivory my name is cabbie
richards thank you so much for joining
us on a tuesday
and we are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you